how do you get a movie made can you
explain the exact process if only there
was a process
there's so many different ways to get a
movie made
um and and that's partly the the tricky
part is where to start and what what
method to go about it
um but fundamentally it requires
resources it requires money
um enlisting people on your vision and
having a very clear vision of what you
want to do and how you want that to
interact with the world
um so I would say
you know it it obviously it starts with
a good story you know you then have to
have
um resources or people contributing
resources to that
um but it is it's it's certainly not
easy
um and so it it takes a lot of
determination and and uh and Gusto to to
keep it moving so it sounds like each
project that you've worked on because
you have quite a few under your belt or
that you've been a part of is different
each time yeah every every project that
that comes together is is a bit
different
um and usually it takes a tremendous
amount of uh
I guess me believing in myself that uh
we can pull something off even when it
looks like uh the odds are stacked
against us
um
there's been projects where we were a
week away from filming and we didn't
have all the money to finish filming and
it was just you know we'll get there
we'll figure it out and then we were
able to close the financing last week of
filming
um at least for me you know there's
always a strong sense in which like
things always seem to work themselves
out and uh and so I think that's in turn
sort of led to a lot of confidence
um and also you know that I put myself
around other people who I can depend on
and rely on and uh
um yeah and sometimes you know take
these risks but we sort of say okay
we'll figure it out as we go
so if you were to help another filmmaker
that has never made a film and let's
suppose they want to get an investor do
you have the script first or do you have
someone that you think can get you to
that investor and you have just an idea
and you certainly in going to an
investor have to have all of your sort
of ducks in a row you need to have a
script you need to have a lookbook you
need to have a budget as it's sort of
been outlined you know for me
um you need to show them that you have a
good idea and that you have the people
to be able to pull it off
and so it's those key things and also
what I found too is uh momentum behind
you you have to have momentum behind you
because it's always very easy for that
investor to say I love it I want to put
money into it but let me know when
you're a little further along
and so you need to give a clear sense
that well this is going right we're
we're a month away from filming or we're
you know this is right around the corner
and you need to also mean it right it's
not it's not um uh just a sort of smoke
and mirror it's like if that investor
goes away you need to also know that you
are filming
um you know definitely don't over
oversell
um but it's that type of environment
that um that brings people in and and
gets people excited and
um and certainly in believing in
yourself others are also going to
believe in in you too
and so a lookbook would be used even for
a documentary certainly I mean people
love visuals and they
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to sell something uh to somebody
that doesn't exist
right if I said hey I've got this house
do you want to buy it I've got these
blueprints it's not going to be as
effective as if I say well now you can
walk through this whole CAD design of
the house itself right you can even put
on this VR headset and sort of walk into
the home and take a look right then it's
real then it's real and that's always
the hardest thing is how to and this is
why people you know do sort of like what
they call rip-o-matics where they kind
of re-cut other films to kind of give a
sense of the look and style
um because it's it's you're trying to
make something real now that people can
put their money into
uh that
um that gives a whole you know 3D uh
sort of fully immersive view of um of
what it is to to watch that film
ultimately in theaters
how often are you hired as a director
and how often are you working as a
director on one of your own projects
um as often as possible I'm directing
projects of my own
um and then from time to time I am also
hired on other projects
um it is I say no to a lot more that I'm
asked to direct but
it does happen and and certainly you
know getting into larger and larger
films
um and certainly open to the idea but uh
um I've just found that the stories that
I kind of cultivate
um whether it's buying a script or
whether it's uh you know writing
something my own or hiring a writer to
do
um that that generally
in putting out all that time
I can increase the odds greatly that
that film will actually get made
um where whereas you know sometimes
projects that come in they are moving
and then Things Fall Apart and then they
come back again
um and so I think largely it's a
function of of time and
um and also just how far and how ready
that project is to go before I step into
to direct it
when you see buying a script are you
actively looking for ones on let's say a
website that has scripts for sale or are
people presenting them to you
so people will contact me from time to
time
um we generally don't uh accept
unsolicited materials
um there's a couple companies around
town that
I've asked to just sort of pass me
projects if they really believe in them
and then I have a sort of network of
writers that I that I know that all you
know hire on on various things
um we don't option projects which is a
bit different than other companies
because our view is that if we're going
to make the film we're going to make the
film so
um you know we're not kind of wasting
time on on optioning it so we just just
outright by it and
um yeah but but you know it's it's
always a very fluid project process and
um you know for now we kind of have the
next two projects set out and kind of
made our calendar for the rest of 2022.
um but uh
um but yeah it's it's never it's never
you know precise
um but we we always are looking for for
projects that really resonate and that
we feel can can connect with audiences
do you think there's an energy to
working on multiple projects at one time
certainly having lots of irons in the
fire is is I I feel a necessity for
working in film
um you know sometimes things just take
longer after availability and you know
things need to be moved around and so uh
to go back and say okay well this one
we're gonna you know bump up on the
priority list as a result can be really
really helpful and there's certainly a
strong sense of convergence of working
with different actors or different
distributors or different sales
companies that then kind of provide the
infrastructure for more films to to come
down a similar path and uh and so
certainly you know as as many irons in
the fire as possible without you know
compromising quality and
um and yeah without compromising you
know the core things of what it is to
make a good movie
do you have like a different spreadsheet
for each project like how do you
delineate each one
um I tend to just kind of keep it all in
my head
so we uh I keep it a to-do list
um basically weekly of sort of full you
know double page of all the things that
need to happen on a specific project and
um and then when I do go into direct I
basically pass all of the tasks off on
other projects uh off to my other
producers or other coordinators and the
reason is is directing I feel needs to
be completely all in that everything
around is quiet that you're just there
being present to you know all the
department heads to the actors and and
to that story and that world itself
how do you raise money for a movie
um the way to raise money for a film is
really to you know start with the people
that you know
um if you're doing an independent film
you know there's there's crowdfunding
platforms
um or it's to package the film and
really you know put a director on board
to put actors on board to put other key
producers on board
and then to take it to a studio you know
to take it to a production company or to
take it to independent film financiers
um there's so many different ways and
scales and and manners to pull together
a film depending on the genre and the
budget level
um but what I always always do and I
think this is why you know I've I've
been able to turn around so many films
is I sort of put what's the best you
know case scenario the you know
sometimes millions of dollars that it
would take to pull a project off
and then what's the scenario where we
absolutely you know bare minimum we're
able to pull this off while still having
really good production production value
and so we create this kind of accordion
between the two
um and oftentimes you know we may say
okay well here's you know what the
number is but we still don't have it uh
how can we start how can we at least
sort of move things further down the
line you know build sets and hire people
and you know get things get things going
uh so that we show that this is
happening this is the vision
um and then you know bring in investors
as as we go
can you talk about how you've done that
with your last three films which I
believe are all documentaries in one
narrative or no
um yeah so for my last couple films the
way we've really leaned into you know
making the movie first and keeping that
as a priority and then you know Finance
is coming later
um is first on a project that I'm doing
um with the writer of Ratatouille called
the inventor
uh it's a stop-motion film that
um that is just very very time consuming
to do so we actually launched first with
a Kickstarter and um and then used you
know some of that money to get the the
studio up and running and we build sets
and we built puppets and costumes and
and
um and simultaneously we raised private
Equity uh from other folks and and that
funded the studio for an entire year
and
um we haven't announced it yet but um
we've got a pretty two pretty big
distribution deals that are that are
about to land
um and that's because we we showed you
know this is we believe in ourselves we
believe in this film you know we had top
talents attached to it and
um and we took it to to can you know
most recently and did a number of deals
there and and are just about to announce
our next one
um but that was just like leaning into
it right like and constantly questions
were how do we keep the studio open how
do we keep everybody paid and we just
kept figuring it out month by month and
getting a little bit further do we need
to put things on pause you know do we
need to spread out the work over a
longer period of time
and and ultimately you know everything
just kept falling into place every
single month
um but it was a very much a leap of
faith
um and I I have this you know I have the
saying of of any film I'm working on
there's always there's a moment where it
says like there's always a test there's
always something that happens that that
sort of this this voice from the world
saying
do you really do you really want this
you know do you really want to make this
film okay show me uh and so that's
that's those those sort of major leaps
of faith that um you know you'll jump
with your team uh that you have
something really special and ultimately
you know you'll land but um it's
certainly a lot of risk and and
um I wouldn't recommend it for everybody
did you get the top name Talent attached
uh after the crowdfunding
um we
had them attached before
we had them attached before
we um
yeah we had shot a teaser for the film
um to sort of give people an idea of the
look uh we just literally at each step
of the way we're like how can we drive
this forward now you know and just time
and time again and then how can we find
other partners that can help
um
there's a quote you know when you begin
tact you discover your hidden allies
and so it's so important to to act to
get out there and to to engage with
people and find those allies who who
believe in your your vision as much as
you do
and then to what you said earlier that
there's there will be a point where the
universe will say are you sure you
really want this and do you want this
and maybe you need to show me and and
that to really you know yeah I think I'm
sure every project has at least one or
two of those moments yeah and then the
other two that you uh financed or had
financed yeah so the other the other two
projects where we did something similar
was again where we sort of set off not
having all the funds
um and raised it you know sometimes in
the final weeks of filming and
um but uh
but yeah I mean always it was it was
and it you know this isn't like insane
risk like we we always had a and we're
never asking you know any of the people
that work for us to take any risk
whatsoever uh but it essentially was
well we either raise the money or we put
it on a bunch of credit cards
um and you know we didn't have to do
that
um but uh but yeah it did really take
that and I think it's so hard to make
independent film these days I mean
especially adding in kovid that
um
you just have to be super hungry and you
know and in my case you know things have
worked out but it certainly hasn't been
from a lack of trying
right and then one of your documentaries
you had um iced tea involved yeah and so
did did he approach you with a film or
you had already been working on it so we
did a film called Public Enemy Number
one that looked at drug use in America
and
um and we also knew that we wanted to
get the word out there and specifically
about how this was locking up minorities
left and right and this is obviously
such a terrible Legacy of of the drug
war and so we reached out to um to ice
tease people and um and showed him the
project and and he came on and did an
interview for us and and also became an
executive producer of the film
and um and you know I've been very
fortunate that other you know of my
projects we've had really
um uh fantastic and generous
um you know high profile individuals
come on board and say you know this is
something that that we see is as
important
um whether it was seven days in in Syria
uh with Angelina Jolie or our most
recent project how to build a truth
Engine with George Clooney
um that uh that really helped help to
get out into the world and and that of
course you know helps with Distributors
and
um and builds momentum so the way that I
found to bring on executive producers is
first
[Music]
um
find out people that really you know are
sympathetic to that particular cause you
know people that
um ultimately you want to create a
win-win and people aren't going to just
you know out of out of pity or or out of
um you know one reason or another say
say yes to a project like it needs to be
organic it needs to be core values and
that's what it is about you know Finding
fellow fellow allies
and um
and so yeah you know we just sort of ask
around and and you know call their reps
and uh you know put a teaser in front of
them and you know if it's an immediate
no you know so be it but we just um uh
uh really
yeah really show that just with their uh
involvement you know projects can can
really take flight and um and sometimes
you know people are willing to help and
and it's phenomenal when they do and
um and then we're also very very
respectful of their time and uh you know
of them lending their name and
um
and it's it's it's a it very much is
about Mutual trust and so you know you
need to be in a place to be able to to
gain that or establish that uh in in any
you know relationship and working with a
a high pro profile EP
and so with seven days in Syria it was a
finished film and then you showed it to
Angelina Jolie exactly exactly okay and
then but with uh the the movie about uh
you said Public Enemy
um the most recent oh yeah Public Enemy
Number One also is finished it was
finished oh okay and then you got iced
tea to to do the interview exactly and
we cut it into the film oh interesting
okay and then with this latest film if
you're yeah with how to build the truth
engine
um we have a uh sort of sample edit of
the project and so that's something
we've been you know taking out and
showing to uh to different people and um
and that's really what what uh was sort
of the tease of of saying okay this
isn't just words on a page I can see the
quality of the filmmaking I can see you
know the characters you're following and
you know in New York Times and others
that um that yeah there's no
question mark about what the vision and
what the impact is here
um and and you know finding people that
are ready to jump onto that